[Music]
brian joins us in toronto brian welcome
to the ramsay show
hi guys thank you very much for having
me absolutely we're doing great how can
we help
uh i'm a recent graduate i'm 22 years
old and i graduated with my uh degree
debt free in april awesome i decided to
take the year off because i wanted to
pursue a master's of public health next
year but i wanted to be able to cast one
and i felt that i needed to develop my
professional skills
i had an internship in toronto
um and i secured that internship and
when i thought there at the community
health center uh the first words out of
my supervisor's notes were you earned my
first choice uh management made me hire
you
uh my question for you guys and it just
happened like two or three days ago
my question for you guys is what can i
do to salvage this relationship and make
it to turn this experience into a mature
one that will help me realize my goal of
strengthening my cv and my professional
development
dude this is a this is a fun situation
john this is your super bowl so uh
i'm just saying i may have had that
happen to me a few times just saying i
think i've been the second or third
choice most of they ran through like 40
different personalities before they're
like god just hard to lonely then that's
all we got left so dude i've been there
a bunch brian um a couple of things i'd
recommend you do first thing is
brush this off like jay-z said brush
your shoulders off dude you got to move
on from this okay
that in some ways that was somebody
trying to weaponize like radical honesty
and they were trying to make a power
play okay i'm not gonna give that a
second thought you know why because you
got the job
who cares who made you higher you got it
the second thing i'm gonna do is i'm
going to
reach out not because i'm trying to make
a move or this is a good political thing
no because i'm a person of dignity i'm
going to say hey i'd love to take you to
coffee or can we set up some time and
here's something i do with all of my
bosses even at ramsey solutions i've
done this i did this with all of my
other buses is i would ask
how do you like to get information are
you a lunch person a coffee person do
you not take lunches with different
people um how do you if there's a crisis
how do you want me to call you if
they're i want to be as hospitable and i
want to be the employee that helps them
be successful in their job
and i take notes and then i say great i
will go from there i've had bosses say i
don't do lunches under coffee with
anybody who reports to me and i said
great and i've had somebody say i like
to do office in my office so if you'll
go pick it up i'd love to meet with you
once a month but i've had it all over
the place but you go first
and here's the third magic thing are you
ready this is gonna be the
brand new news for you so i want you to
hang on to your to your seatbelts on
this one okay
do incredible work
and be fun to be around
the the gold standard is do your job
real well and don't be an idiot
right if you do those two things and
they still don't like you then your boss
has a problem that you can't solve man
and
you're still gonna leave this year or
the next year or whatever this ends up
turning into for you with some great
experience you're going to learn how to
navigate some of these wild political
systems and you're going to get some
great leadership experience and you're
not going to sacrifice your soul in the
process man okay can you do that will
you just go work real hard
and be a person a character absolutely
that helps a lot uh like i said it just
kind of caught me off guard the first
words out of your american league
but so think about it this way thank you
two kids just showed up to the
schoolyard
and
one of them was like hey man my name is
is george
and the other one just takes his shirt
off and flexes real big and goes look at
my muscles that's what just happened to
you and dude i like it's like cool
muscles bro can we go play on the slides
that's what happened don't give it a
second thought just work really hard be
a person at character and you go first
with how can you serve your supervisor
man good for you congratulations i love
that out of a sea of analogies you chose
the shirt off flexing john
that may have happened to me as well
well brian i i've been in your shoes too
i started at ramsey solutions as an
intern and while the team was very
loving there were people who just went
ah i don't buy it yeah this guy's not
for me not my cup of tea and i had to
prove them wrong not with a chip on my
shoulder but just going hey i'm happy to
be here i'm going to work my tail off i
want to be a guy that people like to be
around and here i am eight years later
yeah so that's the best advice i can
give is prove them wrong and don't do it
in a in a revengeful way but just kind
of like all right that's cool man i'm 22
i get it i'm a young buck don't have a
lot of experience
i'm here to get experience yeah so
uh three years from now he's probably
gonna be he's gonna go man that that's
that's my guy right there three years
from now his resume will be on your desk
and then you can say wow
yep good to see you yeah that's how it
is man prove them wrong i love it all
right